you
there we go double the points and fly
alright let's see if I can I'm gonna do
something different after this have I
done enough yet that is it King side
castle it could be happening h2
no way okay let's take here and then
here and here
not so fast okay let's regroup on push
Bishop here Bishop here and then pawn
takes a couple times here our two pieces
take on this square on push Bishop c5
still Bishop c5 it is Queens gun very
common move but not in this position of
course
Queen is gone she's not bothering me I'm
not taking her why not take her she was
officially a completely free queen I was
forgetting about that detail I was I was
thinking oh and now she's unpinned what
am i dealing Wow
ha ha ha I see tricks though I see
tricks Queen here is a matin 1 2 3 right
queen g 3 pawn takes pawn push pawn may
new clean that rook remains pinned 7
seconds this is still on Queen g3 get to
play it
back to tournament they're down on time
that's a weird start to a tournament
okay Wow
that time just moves super fast doesn't
it all right let's try 4c for liven it
up in the center let's go for a quick
Knight c3 and let's take once
let's pin the night I'll consider taking
here only after the bishop has moved
castle or rook on c1 hitting two pieces
now the bishop probably has to return
Castle kept in the night and then take
here on a six I think I'll drop back to
e2
hmm
I have a structural change no it's a pin
nine just one upon
here
hmm
I could do this because this night at
the end of it is pinned hit three times
all right just take with my queen there
come up up two pawns flight square I
like my a pawn trade even on time
definitely go for that whoa
flight square babysit my pawn but should
be okay we're going to get my a pawn but
my candle will eventually get very
active okay now they're not getting my
upon thing crew gate to was best 13
seconds why to give up that pond not
quite sure I have these answers oh man
four three two anything the rook down on
time back to tournament twelve twelve
seven I'm in 14th still very early four
minutes into the tournament
okay let's try D five on e4 Scandinavian
we'll see oh those guys
moving
should be a quick win back to tournament
gotta move within 15 seconds otherwise
it's game over for twelves 25 minutes
remain
fired up otherwise I don't know what to
say become tongue-tied games not
starting what do I say here I need to
see pieces flying around comment on them
ok let's try to break at this Center
okay let's take here before it's
supported in the pond could take like
this mmm ok yeah let's try to put
pressure on this pond right away if g6
play ooh oh no I'm losing material no
I'm not man Knight takes a my knight on
each floor was unprotected I got a run
with it trade light square bishop sand
I'll have a monster night this looks
wild what I'm gonna do it it's
definitely it looks wild
I should have light square control
though I should be able to maintain them
my knight and my queen will do that do
the job for that let's glue my queen
here my night here pawn push might be an
idea ok oh right here scariness Wow is
this getting scary oh my goodness
big trouble very big trouble he's gotta
go mean do I really think I could live
with that night around that fiend kettle
tonight I need to fly need to fly have
him covered
you
rook trade the other rooks gonna come
down and give check I'm gonna get that
rook easy my knight is tricky oh I got
the brook no no no is it my move
it's not even my mom phone nope seven
point six it's gonna be all about time
that's all it's coming to Forks fork
town no why would you do that
then I penny time though it could be
sneaky check wild and crazy stuff
another check there down on time back to
tournament it to be a mouse artist those
final seconds they're critical
don't look for objectively good moves
look for time burnin moves nap three I
haven't played this guy in a while hmm
recalling to die play like was this from
like the first one of the first warzone
tournaments I had let's I think I played
him and like he was one of the top guys
from like war zone or zone tournament
number two I maybe have the wrong guy
I'm hitting this guy twice g3 that
provides this hook and now the H files
gonna open up okay I'm on g3 I defend
that and stop the knife from landing
here
don't even think about it I'll give him
up and then look to break
f-for my night is a monster here break
this down here G files ready to open up
G files officially opened up
and let's give a check throw another
rope here
has to be good I'm on the bishop I could
have taken the bishop
by doing I'm sure what that mom's doing
let's try to get over here oh they're
kind of they're really stuck they are
very very stuck may threat here
happening soon yes Annie to back to
tournament 42 42 30 30 30 all right
hmm Queen B 3 and then Knight c3 might
Bishop out here and only then III
the rook opposite their Queen could have
considered h4 I want to get wild and
crazy okay
let's go here if I take there would have
been a problem on h2 41 seconds let's
get this in
I'm gonna back up my rip belongs on the
c-file opposite the coin that pawns in a
pin um I guess I gotta take
he is tricky there in a pin it's a self
pin
who needed that or trades
throw my night somewhere
okay king is cut off
he is sealed in there now my knight
needs to be right there and that's going
to be a mate they have a move with the
pond it's a very important detail
otherwise would be stalemate back
determine I was going to run up with my
king but I saw that mating now and
throwing the knight on f6 okay 56 56
what do I have 42 or only 10 minutes
into this one okay
starting up right away at least
hmm not starting come on 56 56
six games in those top two guys have
seven
oh I better get awarded points if this
game doesn't start if there's an error
72 somebody has eight games and I only
have six oh man um what do you do here
all you do is stare at a clock 18
minutes and change
ah come on this is brutal
this is way too time-consuming here we
go
get out of that give me some points I
got seven points for that I was at 42
will bobsled okay
let's stop b5 castle d4 gang at this
face advantage now when I kick that
night away secure my night position
first though they probably should play
Bishop f5 sooner yeah
Bishop f5 I think still would have been
good now the knight is dead hmm I didn't
realize that that was actually going to
be the case
Bishop e6 and then d5 even at the cost
of the b-pawn I don't want to go in that
direction Knight f4 just get rid of the
light squared bishop he's the most
dangerous of the two bishops he could
get exchange of South file for this guy
it's the light square bishop I need to
be concerned about okay
take with the Queen among the bishop to
return get the rook over here this pawn
is hit twice this pawn on c5 is also hit
trade dark square bishop sand plan
tonight on d4 maybe even f5 okay that is
very very damaged structure actually
they made it maybe taking my night here
Knight takes on f6 queen of five if it's
somehow defended house the only way that
it could have been defended I could have
taken here first with the Queen at the
end there is Knight f6
they're down there now they resigned
back determine 90 72 72 no 72 70 and I
have 63 now okay gambler the all right
let's try this some dragon okay Bishop
to e3 Bishop g4 stopped and rook c8
let's take Bishop takes pawn there's b6
he's probably going to be trapped get a
clean trader my night is going to be
anchored soon uncie five I want to get
an 85 a dark square grip a5 let's kick
the knight first then play here I want
to get him out of my position first and
like I was saying a knight on c5 is
going to be a monster
let's take him out dar square control my
king up mmm Oh more dark squares what
are we going to have I get my king
centralized pawn push and then I'll have
all right there's nothing happening over
there 20 seconds he came out of there
need to go in a different position I
know that pump push actually maybe it's
to lockdown
can be taken I could still open up this
position actually pawn push is going to
be the break take that night out he has
to be super annoying okay so they took
their get over here give a check here
probably no matter what here now the
pawns defended on push just want to
trade they're down on time back to
tournament 110 I got way too positional
dark square control good night versus
bad Bishop type of position halfway
point okay a quick castle maybe shoot
for d4 now that it's supported enough d5
d6
to temple gaining moves maybe before I
do d6 I want to make sure that Knight f5
move is not on pinpoint this it makes
the queenside development difficult he's
falling now Queen d2 maybe eliminate
dark square Bishop Fisher to f4 Bishop
h6 or maybe not right away I want to
insert Bishop to g5 first or get this
rook working in fact let's push and
let's
punch of the Queen let's play here I
have enough defense of this pond I do
I'm night here maybe night h2 he's
probably the most annoying piece let's
try and get rid of them I stopped enough
defense for this that nights in a pin I
want to take them right now and ready to
lose this pawn I have the two minor
pieces now it's back up
Bishop to g2 pretty even on time I was
probably unnecessary Bishop here in
Queen h6 was more to the point
Oh Queen's gone almost missed that
bishops hit and the rook is hit probably
going to resign they resigned back to
term at 1:30 I got to catch this guy
he's got 11 games in 13 minutes
remaining 130 97 if we get paired up
I'll be certainly a big game howdy
equator wins in this is often a quick
way to get a quick win these little
sneak attacks here on h2 remove the
knight i takes Knight Queen each to mate
I takes Knight check queen h2 mate it's
not happening hitting the bishop let's
break that pin doubled pawns I don't
know hour all that bad there Bishop is
bad throw a punch back at the nutty
Bishop d7 this is very useful doubled
pawn watching over D v a5 first maybe
okay let's weaken some dark squares my
bishop will be really strong vision of
g5 cannot be stopped Queen d8 if the
queen is trying to control that I
probably should not have done that mo
where's my King gonna go oh really
let's drop back here
I give that up really want to go to
Queen trade it's this let's get b5 in
I'll get that pond back just want to
open files for my rooks now let's keep
this rook over here he is a passed pawn
after all that each pawn and it
discouraged that type of idea
there's no Bishop moves with check
now I'm going to push King here and I
win a piece
okay the request to go to one of these
two I have that pond mate threat this
has to block that is me who 117 whoa
where'd everybody come from there 138
131 28 117 hmm
okay let's go stay focused here just
about a game out 20 points will put me
up to 137 top is 138
whew this guy's not moving this might be
exactly what I need a quick 20 point
boost
yes 138 137 130 128 10 minutes remain
I love pizza okay light square weakness
on f3 really like to see that light
square bishop exchanged
okay weakens the seventh rank and this
diagonal rook c8 a lot of Queen moves
let's take care pin the night and throw
my net on e4 let's just go here I could
have played 94 probably but big light
square control right now this rook is
ideally placed to let's just kick her
away for a moment
Knight is here Forks on this square
castle probably no matter what maybe I
could have thrown that check in unless
Bishop d4 I'm taking this fish up with
check in this case where is the quick
mate that's it no it's not
make sure there's no Queen takes rook
here it's happening soon it must be
happening soon there it is back to
terminal 157 158 157 algorithm 117
yes rookie all right now they're going
to take the pawn and hang on to it no
they're not all right let's try for some
tricks take the pawn inside Castle I'm
going all-in keep this closed take that
pawn and probably throw the knight in
here I should've done that I want to do
that to avoid the opening of the a or B
files is he going to be taken yet
all right I want to win a pond here and
take yet get on the H file quick now
he's got to go come over here 30 seconds
can I even still try this I'm insisting
on getting to this square definitely
insisting Queen takes pawn that's with
check rook block I have g6 feels way too
good to not do in fact this is leading
to me back to tournament 177 168 158
seven minutes remain who John four five
six eight five two okay all right all
right let's go with this capture first
and then castle or I should have sent a
bishop capture before my bishop moves I
don't know why I unpinned that night I'm
winning a piece now I'm on the rook and
what other dangerous stuff can I do
Knight here okay he's rescued okay I'm
on the rook and the bishop the dark
squares are getting hit a real lot up
another piece let's drop back with tempo
ah Queen trade alright still up that
piece and another one right now
got a block with one of the ponds I got
a meeting that check their night move
with check maybe soon check here got a
lot of pieces around the King ooh
any threat rook here finally back
determine 208 197 less than six minutes
remain
to catch that guy oh this is the guy ah
start out with a mouse lip never good
sign this is the big game so for the
tournament I think oh let me down the
exchange maybe not this guy is flying
he's definitely flying really want to
kill out the show
alright let's get some dark square stuff
going on
mmm sneaky stuff I guess I'll take
bishop gonna move hang on hang on I was
getting scared there don't get made it I
got the bishop it's very useful throw a
check
just gained some time here on that pond
taking that pun my bishop is really good
right here and then here get that rook
up King here workout for also out of a
pin f7 is collapsing soon-to-be mate
whoa soon as that Bishop dropped it
became very difficult can't stop me for
much longer
that's me back to tournament big win
whoo
217 206 I need to try and stay ahead now
try and get two more games in okay
d5 let's take care of the Knights head
I'll hang out of that pond you take me I
am helped with my development I probably
should have taken that pawn twice I'll
take them now we take with the Queen and
I can't move I'm on the bishop
cleany - I think e six okay there's
still no danger here my queen is in a
good spot
I guess maybe pinned in some lines Queen
trade take like this preserve my pawn
now I had Queen takes here oh it's just
the removed well oh well keep running
they're gonna move there we go
I just got a night one night here would
have been kicked even on time
King position my knight in a better spot
night c4 this game is not ending anytime
fast he's sort of in a pin bishops there
to watch over this i takes b2 or a 383
i'm on the bishop on push there's Knight
f5 here is a threat very serious one
because this is also potential loose
piece let's hang out of my night first
night here is an idea mate Knight moves
it's me unless he goes here late next
move Knight has to block back to
tournament 237 216 oh that's big that's
21-point lead I get this I think it's
definitely over I'm up basically two
games at this point just unless I lose
this in my opponent and that guy in
second catches up got to make sure I
don't lose this that what a play to win
play to win a bunch of captures
happening on e5 not quite
circulate now I'm gonna go in this
direction I was going to go Knight f1 g3
trade dark-squared bishop s' their King
side is a bit weak 35 seconds whatever
you do do not lose this game I have
enough defense on this double rooks wide
have to retreat my Queen move forward
get movin forward okay get rid of that
Knight like g5 look it here first take
with the pawn
mmm weakening
I've done this coins on that square
where's my knight want to be on f6
um let's do this and take here take here
with check take the rook throw my knight
here watch out for this g2 square I'm on
the bishop though entering with my queen
and it's gonna be called I think it was
just called oh I am tired first please
confetti land good games all oh that was
way too many tournaments in a row
oh and that guy one two hole man - 37 -
36 - 18 - 11 200 wow they had not I only
had 16 games in fair a fair tournament
nothing sneaky going on as far as number
of games and such all right
oh man tired town
you
[Music]